nous défendons les intérêts de tous les
secteurs comprend le système de gestion
de la pour des familles qui ont réussi à
gagner leur vie
c'est leur gagne pain est en train de
brader le premier ministre est en train
de négocier avec un manque de
transparence
je comprends aussi que ça mais les gens
mal à l'aise mais une fois que les
tribunaux statuent et c'est ça nouveaux
citoyens qui se joint à notre famille
canadienne à visage découvert c'est un
enjeux soulevés par des politiciens qui
n'ont rien aux frais de qui ne voient
que je fais ça c'est marginal bonds
importants sont en rupture avec
lesquelles edward le niqab donc le
partenariat transpacifique une embellie
économique une rose dans les sondages
la dernière semaine a été fructueuse
pour les conservateurs sont ils en train
de gagner leur pari d'une très longue
campagne
ils sont là tous les trois daniel et à
ottawa tasha à toronto
michel à montréal bonsoir à vous trois
alors je vais commencer avec vous tout
achat ce truc partenariat transpacifique
s'il est signé qu'est ce que ça change à
la campagne qu'est ce que ça donne aux
conservateurs mais ça ajoute à leur
kabylité économique
ils ont misé depuis très longtemps sur
le libre échange comme une façon
d'augmenter les emplois de croître
l'économie
alors s'ils réussissent à le signer en
pleine élection ils peuvent dire bon ça
va augmenter surtout nos échanges avec
le pacifique ce qui l'a aidé ray en
colombie britannique en particulier qui
veut avoir plus de liens économiques
avec l'asie en ce qui a trait à la
gestion de l'offre ça peut leur nuire au
québec effectivement un peu un matériau
où on voit que c'est votre
nécessairement la meilleure chose pour
les producteurs laitiers qui tiennent à
ce système il ya du mécontentement
daniel oui sauf que la gestion de
l'offre in pardon c'est devenu un
système de plus en plus difficile à
défendre dont le gouvernement canadien
il ya deux pays sur la planète qui ont
ce genre de système là le canada israël
c'est très peu la plupart des autres
vont abandonner fallait le dire souvent
remplacés par des subventions énormes
c'est vrai la gestion de l'offre comme
tel ça ne sera pas suffisant pour
empêcher la conclusion de cet accord
dont c'est un accord extrêmement
importants ont dit dans plusieurs
milieux
politique autour de stephen harper
financier que le canada ne peut pas ne
pas signer cette entente c'est trop
ah les opposants la mondialisation à au
capitalisme de tous grands vont dire bon
pourquoi on s'envoie l'attend sauf que
c'est la façon de faire les choses en ce
moment et pour une fois que le japon
ouvre ses portes et en passant ce sera
moins bon pour les producteurs de porcs
du québec
pour une fois que le japon ouvre ses
portes tout petit peu aux autres pays le
canada peut pas rester là à dire nous
rossine pas parce qu'on aime pas on
n'aime pas on abandonner ou le sacrifier
le parti de gestion alors on verra la
version finale et les détails mais
chelle mais quand même il y aura des
perdants au québec et ça veut dire que
stephen harper il sacrifie comme dit je
sais bien comme vous il faudra voir
exactement ce qu'il ya dans le traité
jusqu'où on va ouvrir les marchés pour
les produits laitiers en particulier
mais de façon générale je pense que tout
le monde s'entend posé qui aura il y
aura des dégâts causés dans l'industrie
maintenant les espoirs des conservateurs
étaient limités au québec
alors ils feront certainement le calcul
que les dégâts vont l'être aussi et je
pense que oui ça peut causer du tort
dans quelques circonscriptions
mais au total je pense que la gageure de
monsieur harper est excellente et je
vous rappellerai aussi juste pour
mémoire que au moment de l'accord de
libre échange avec les états unis
tout le monde les syndicats au québec
compris le pays avait poussé des grands
cris puis finalement ça c'était plus ou
moins bien passé alors il est un peu tôt
pour conclure tant qu'on aura pas vu en
toute l'étendue des dommages
évidemment on est en pleine campagne
électorale daniels et le gouvernement a
droit de faire de négocié cet accord
pendant qu'on est en campagne mais est
ce que ça lui donne toute la légitimité
écoutez normalement il ya des protocoles
qui disent que la campagne électorale
c'est une période de transition et que
premier ministre sortant ci doit signer
des ententes importantes doit consulter
ses adversaires si vous avez vous savez
pas très fort sur la consultation ne
fait même pas pensé de consulter trudeau
et mesquer là dessus sauf que et ce
qu'il faut rappeler ce que ce genre de
traiter et c'est vrai pour le traité sur
l'union européenne où on n'a pas encore
réussi à s'entendre sur un texte final
il faut d'abord peaufiner
réussira à prendre ce texte final donc
il faudra faire ça aussi avec le
partenariat transpacifique à une fois
qu'on a un texte final il faut que ce
soit prouvée dans toutes les provinces
alors si monsieur couillard n'aime pas
l'abandon ou la modification de la
gestion de l'offre
aussi madame wayne en ontario et
furieuse parce qu'on veut sacrifier
l'industrie des pièces automobiles
ils ont le pouvoir de dire non à et
c'est là où justin trudeau et bruns et
thomas mulcair sont un peu sur la
clôture son plus comme le niqab cela une
arme à deux tranchants
michael est annoncé le mot daniel le
report malheureusement faut en parler
parce que ça a pris une telle importance
dans cette campagne
même dans le reste du canada tasha pas
seulement au québec comment expliquer ce
qui s'est passé ben écoute le
gouvernement ne contrôle pas la cour la
décision est tombée le gouvernant était
en position de décider est ce qu'on va
en appel de cette décision là et les
conservateurs sont dit oui jeudi en
france qu'il ya quand même une
instrumentalisation la delacourt écoute
la cause et la poésie
ben on écoute la décision d'aller en
appel ça me surprend personne
les conservateurs depuis longtemps
disent qu'ils sont en faveur de prendre
la cérémonie de citoyenneté à visage
découvert et c'est une position qui est
appuyé par la majorité des canadiens non
seulement au québec
alors pour eux premièrement c'est
politiquement si l'on se sente assez
certain là-dessus mais je pense aussi et
deuxièmement c'est une question une rare
question de principe qui tombe dans une
campagne
on dit toujours on critique nos
politiciens de ne pas parler de principe
et leur père de principes et de valeurs
les gens n'aiment pas ça alors on peut
pas l'avoir de deux façons moi je pense
c'est un débat légitime et qu'il devrait
la voir
michèle ouimet enfin il faut quand même
bien reconnaître que c'est sur une
technicalité dans le fond que les
conservateurs ont lancé ce débat là
c'est sa peau était jugée sur le fond de
l'ipo question de savoir si c'est
compatible ou non avec l'achat
simplement qu'un règlement peut pas
l'emporter sur une loi mais le résultat
de tout ça c'est que c'est sur la table
effectivement est sur la table 2
des électeurs si je peux dire et au
québec il est clair que ça fait
d'énormes ravages dans les rangs en
particulier des démocrates les libéraux
sont un peu à l'abri de ça parce que
leur clientèle et allophones et
anglophones est généralement d'accord
avec les positions de ce trou d'eau mais
on l'a vu à l'assemblée nationale on a
parlé un peu plus tôt il ya eu une
motion qui a été adoptée et là c'est
comme si tous les vieux démons
on constatait que tous les vieux démons
qui était sorti dans la durant le débat
sur la charte était tout d'un coup
réapparu et et on se dit qu'ils seront
pas nécessairement prêts à retourner
dans leur boîte une couple a un coût que
la campagne va être terminés les dégâts
qui sont fait maintenant vont
probablement perdurer et au québec il ya
des débats encore qui s'en viennent
on nomme il y aura une réécriture du
projet 59 sur le discours est nommé il
ya un projet 62 sur les comme disait
commodément raisonnable qui va s'en
venir aussi ça va donner lieu à une
discussion alors est ce que on veut
revivre le climat qu'on a vécu au moment
du débat sur la charge je pense que
poser la question c'est tout à fait ce
trajet je pense l'inquiétude réelle des
parlementaires et de beaucoup de gens au
québec
bon daniel c'est vrai le niqab a coûté
cher à thomas mulcair est ce qu a juste
le niqab cependant qui explique cette
érosion des appuis de tamanu caire
quelques années le niqab est
probablement le plus gros problème en ce
moment de thomas mulcair mais pas le
seul car fait at on fait des erreurs
pendant cette campagne la première est
fait la plus importante c'est de ramener
le nouveau parti démocratique au centre
de l'échiquier de promettre des défis 7
0 c'est pas du tout dans la philosophie
dans l'adn des néo-démocrates ses
produits doux de cette façon là que les
aigles noirs des loups tommy dahlgren ou
des vélos way se dirigeaient ce parti là
il faut dire aussi que thomas mulcair a
souvent un double langage qui a déplu à
bien des gens même son double non thomas
mulcair au québec
tout ça est agaçant faut dire aussi que
le npd au pas des racines très profondes
au québec il ya une élection où il est
arrivé en tremblement terre sauf
qu'avant le tremblement terre n'y avait
pas de racines et après le tremblement
terre et à plusieurs racines qui ne sont
pas sortis de terre donc il ya il ya
toutes sortes de problèmes et thomas
mulcair et dans son entourage on vous
aussi avec des amis comme ce qu'il avait
dans l'entourage de jean charest à
commencer par jean charest vrac ont
besoin d'ennemis oui monsieur madame
monsieur matière à s'être et d'erreurs
de ramener deux parties au centre mais
je pense y avait pas prévu non plus que
monsieur trudeau prendrait une position
très audacieuse et le double reste sur
sa gauche
moi je pense qu'ils se disaient bon mais
moi je vais rassurer les jeunes qui sont
tannés des conservateurs mais qui
veulent pas d'un régime socialiste au
canada alors il a joué trop conservateur
précisément il s'est fait jour un taux
j'aurais dit exactement michel je suis
d'accord c'est que c'est pas si c'est
que monsieur milquet n'avait pas
vraiment le choix que de dire écoute on
va pas faire un déficit mais il n'avait
pas prévu les change de position entre
les libéraux et le npd sur plusieurs
questions
on voit que les libéraux sont maintenant
à gauche de l'un des deux est là ça fait
que le vote est bd va s'effriter un peu
vers eux c'est les pros dit les
progressistes
on voit aussi que monsieur mulcair sur
d'autres questions il parle à deux
groupes différents et ce peut être pas
les satisfaire pour le projet énergie
est par exemple il ya les syndicats qui
veulent des emplois ils ont des
environnementalistes qui les veulent
qu'ils veulent pas le développement des
sables bitumineux
comment ce que peuvent satisfaire ces
deux gros classé comme le président
obama aux saisies avec kiss dont il a
fait un choix mais celui qu'a aussi et
l'essai de clerc à tout le monde mais
c'est impossible de se faire il doit
faire des choix et dans une contexte
d'une campagne de même de 78 jours c'est
très difficile de faire ça parce qu'à
pas aussi sachant un problème de
confiance un peu en ce moment oui mais
c'est ça le confiance et que monsieur
mulcair doit garder forteresse québec
pour que les gens de l'extérieur du pays
doivent avoir confiance en lui que c'est
la personne à faire sortir monsieur
harper est aussi doivent avoir confiance
point qu'il dit la même chose au canada
anglais qu'en français autrement tu veux
pas avoir confiance à un politicien si
tu penses qu'il double discours et c'est
ça la question maintenant le tomtom à ce
qu'on a fait référence
on a l'impression que c'est plutôt
stephen harper qui profitent de la
baisse 20 millions penser qu'avec des
vases communicants peut-être entre qui
incarnerait mieux le changement justin
trudeau
ou thomas mulcair dernière a recensé
stephen rapp le cheminement qui est je
sais pas si vous avez vu clair durant
dans le devoir
la fonctionnaire derrière elle est
toujours une chose soit exactement quand
on surestime toujours le vote des
conservateurs et en ce moment elle a
parlait de deux ou trois points je
serais pas étonné qu'en ce moment le
vote de civils en plus souvent
sous-estimé en particulier au québec il
ya des stratèges conservateurs qui vont
assez souvent et celle nous vendre leur
salade puis on l'achète pas mais qui
cette fois xixe
surveillez bien le québec vous allez
peut-être avoir des surprises pour parle
pas de cela quand députés ni de 40 ni de
25 mais pas mal plus que les cinq qu'ils
ont eu la dernière fois à y reste deux
semaines qu'est ce qui peut se passer
pour inverser cette tendance là beaucoup
de choses dans la vie que tu as fait
tant de choses qui se passaient dans
cette campagne
ouais mais là je n'ai juste pas si cela
michel d'abord et on reviendra pour le
mot de la fin sur les débats qui s'en
viennent le débat michel willems est
vrai que au québec en particulier à
monsieur apple semble avoir pris à peu
près tout profit qui avait à prendre du
débat sur le niqab mais le bloc en prend
aussi est une des preuves
une des premières conséquences c'est que
ça remis le bloc sur la sur la tribune
jusqu'à présent deux l'entendait pas là
monsieur monsieur duceppe a enfin réussi
à trouver une raison de d'entrer dans le
débat et ça ça peut être très mauvais
aussi pour monsieur mon cas il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne voulaient pas
s'en aller gérer que les conservateurs
mais qui des anciens bloquistes qui
serait dire non quand même pas mais qui
pourrait retourner au bloc maintenant et
ça c'est tout aussi mauvais pour
monsieur mode caire parce que tu achètes
et tantôt à partir du moment où dans le
reste du canada on choisira le npd ait
pu non plus le québec dans sa poche qui
maintenant est l'alternative à devient
évidente le sais monsieur trudeau et on
le voit ces libéraux sont les deuxièmes
choix des néo-démocrates à peu près
partout les positions de monsieur
trudeau plaisent aux néo-démocrates sa
position sur le déficit plaît davantage
que celle de monsieur marc herr même si
les électeurs néo-démocrates
alors là il ya un très gros danger pour
monsieur mollekens passant entre les
conservateurs et le bloc au québec
il reste le débat de demain dernier
débat en français demain du reste aussi
prestation à l'émission tout le monde en
parle quand même qui peut avoir un
certain impact c'est la licence et la
bagarre aujourd'hui lequel il défie de
monsieur mulcair alors comment est ce
qui peut renverser cette micro il peut
pas changer d'idée sur la sur la sur le
niqab
parce que bon c'est une question de
principe et ça c'est encore plus visible
il faut il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
arrivent quelque chose mais quoi je ne
sais pas toi qui dois essayer de ne pas
parler du niqab c'est à dire mettre
l'emphase sur les autres grandes
questions les questions comme les
garderies par exemple c'est c'est une
politique qui plaît aux québécois
qu'elle npd prononcée sauf qu'ils l'ont
déjà
enfin alors on se reparle la semaine
prochaine on sera vraiment dans la
dernière ligne droite 9 de cette
campagne
beaucoup avouent 3-1 et dimanche à 11
heures aux coulisses du pouvoir
emmanuelle latraverse reçoit le chef du
parti libéral du canada justin trudeau